North Korea faces new outrage this
morning after another missile test the
intermediate-range missile traveled far
enough to reach the US military base on
Guam analysts say it was North Korea's
longest missile flight so far
defense secretary Jim mattis called the
launch reckless the UN Security Council
which approved new sanctions against
North Korea this week plans an emergency
meeting this afternoon South Korea's
military says that missile was launched
from an airport near Pyongyang North
Korea's capital it flew for 19 minutes
over the northern Japanese island of
Hokkaido before falling into the Pacific
Ocean Ben Tracy is in Beijing with
reaction to this latest test Ben good
morning good morning so just yesterday
North Korea said Japan should be sunken
into the sea and now it has launched
another missile through its airspace so
if the goal of the last round of UN
sanctions was to get Kim jong-un to take
a break for a bit didn't work sirens
blared in Japan for the second time in
three weeks warning of a North Korean
missile flying overhead just six minutes
after the launch
South Korea fired two ballistic missiles
of its own into view
demonstrating a quick response in the
event of an actual attack North Korea
has now launched 19 missiles this year
its latest flying further than any North
Korean missile ever has about 2,300
miles had North Korea launched it to the
south it would have been able to hit
military bases on the u.s. territory of
Guam about 2100 miles away kim
jeong-hoon may be trying to show he can
make good on his threat to attack the
island Korea is reveling in its defiance
on August 29th it launched a missile
over Japan five days later it conducted
its six nuclear test of what experts
believe was a massive hydrogen bomb
today's missile launch seems to be a
reaction to new UN sanctions passed
Monday banning North Korea's textile
exports and cutting off about 30 percent
of its oil supply I think that North
Korea is attempting to to play us here
defense expert Tom korekiyo says North
Korea is trying to create chaos and
divide US military alliances North
Korea's adept use of threats of rhetoric
of provocations they would love to see
division of various kinds between the
United States and Japan at between the
United States and South Korea the more
that they can divide so much the better
US Secretary of State Rex Tillerson says
it's now time for Russia and China to
take direct action against North Korea
China accounts for about 90 percent of
North Korea's oil supply but it's
resisted an embargo and that's because
it fears if the regime collapses in
North Korea China would be dealing with
a refugee crisis on its order or worse
yet
all right then Tracy in Beijing thank
you